[Musique]
la france doit-elle crier au loup espèce
protégée elle dessine les troupeaux le
gouvernement permettra d'en tuer 40 par
an mais la contestation gronde et le
ministre de l'agriculture de déclaré un
éleveur qui est attaquée à la capacité
de se défendre
au delà du quota vous pouvez vous défend
la france peut-elle envoyer paître
l'europe grâce à des conditions
favorables et des mesures de protection
stricte
le loup a fait son retour en europe
italie d'où viennent les spécimens
français espagne allemagne suisse en
france de 30 et une zone de présence
permanente en 2013 on est passé au
double en 2017 360 individus pile poil
il en vient même à rodez du côté des
frontières dire et j'ai rencontré des
mécanismes le pousser vers as plus de
onze mille fois tué l'an dernier
essentiellement des eaux va panique dont
dans les bergeries le gouvernement via
un plan a décidé de ménager la chèvre et
100 pages pour conjuguer protection de
l'espèce et en même temps à gros
pastoralisme car ce n'est pas l'église
au milieu du village
enfin peut-être l'éleveur au milieu de
la montagne ça va mieux en le disant
ce plan propose d'en abattre 40 par an
maxi pour certains ce n'est pas assez et
même josé bové le vieux loup de terre
est inquiet l'europe ne l'entend pas de
cette oreille
la france en effet ratifié les textes
contraignants pour la protection de la
bête mais des dérogations sont possibles
soit si l'espèce est dans un état de
conservation favorable si d'autres
solutions ne peuvent être trouvées et 6
est pleinement justifiée mais ça ne
tient pas pourquoi une population viable
c'est dix fois plus d'animaux il existe
bien des solutions non létales tous les
loups ne sont pas de sauvages
psychopathe et de plus les autorités à
dennis bien les berges et donc la
déclaration du ministre travers il ya
plus au delà du quota vous pouvez vous
défendre
sous-entendu tuer le loup l'europe avec
ses règles très strictes pourraient
belle avalé de travers c'est donc
contestable